thanks so much for coming in putting up
with a few minutes of technical
difficulties okay so I'm here to give a
lecture today on exploration and meta
reinforcement learning and so this is
just a little outline of the things I'm
planning to talk about so first we're
gonna recap policy gradient and how we
can use that to build some metal
reinforcement learning algorithms that
Chelsey touched on last week and then
we're going to look at the problem of
exploration a little bit more deeply and
finally before the break see an approach
to encourage better exploration then
we'll have a break and afterwards we'll
come back and take a bit of a different
view of meta reinforcement learning
framing it as a pom DP and then we'll
look at how this framing allows us to
design a different algorithm that
crucially is off policy so much more
sample efficient and uses a bit of a
different way to explore and at any
point please raise your hands ask
questions interactive is always better
okay so just to kind of motivate the
whole problem statement learning
approaches have really excelled in
producing agents that are specialists
right they're good at one specific task
but in the real world we'd like our
agents to be generalists skilled at a
variety of behaviors and able to exploit
the structure in the world in order to
learn new things faster so here's a
little nice little to example with some
some art safe surfing skateboarding and
sledding all involve balancing your body
on the board while it moves right so
we'd like the agent to be able to
extract this kind of shared knowledge
between the tasks in order to learn a
new similar task faster so let's briefly
go back to how meta learning works in
the supervised learning case just to
build up some common formalism so in the
supervised learning case say image
classification we'd like to be able to
recognize new classes from just a few
labelled examples and we'll do that by
training across many such small
classification tasks tasks in our
training set so just to get some
notation will say that we are dated our
training set is d-train and we're going
to use some function f they
which I'm not going to to describe at
all right now and just say that F data
extracts some tasks specific information
that I'll call Phii and then I want to
use Phii to make predictions on the test
set right and so then I compute the loss
and I sum over all of my training tasks
so my goal is to maximize performance
across all the training tasks okay so
now let's add the RL formalism in side
by side so an RL now instead of adapting
to a new classification task we want to
adapt to a new MVP so suppose we have
some again going back to our set of M
DPS that involve balancing yourself
right so we want to be able to Train
across the set of MVPs in order to
generalize to a new one and so the
notation will be largely the same again
we have our F theta extracting task
information Phi I and we'll use Phi I to
try to maximize our expected return in
the new MDP so just to get some terms
down now to be clear I'm going to call
this F theta entity the adaptation or
sometimes the inner loop and we'll call
this outer optimization the outer loop
or the méditerranée
and so as we look at these different
algorithms
we'll keep coming back to what does meta
training look like and what does
adaptation look like and so meta
training will generally just simply be
stochastic gradient descent on this
objective but we'll see a lot of
different choices for how adaptation can
work throughout these algorithms okay so
let's look a little deeper at the
differences between these two frameworks
that I've written down so what's the
difference in RL well in supervised
learning notice that new tasks that were
given it's it's all the data is given to
us right someone gave us the training
examples that were labeled and so all
our job was was to figure out how to
adapt quickly given that data but now if
we consider the RL setting when I want
to compute F theta of M I where m is the
MVP I have to figure out how like I'm
not usually give
thus a transition function and reward
function that explicitly defined the MVP
right I'm given experience and have to
choose what experience I'm going to use
to adapt so we introduced this problem
of exploration in addition to adaptation
so now your job is not only to adapt but
also to collect the data that will best
allow you to adapt ok so let's go back
for a second to policy gradients so that
we can build up a mad RL algorithm so in
policy gradient we're doing direct
policy search with a policy PI that
we're going to parameterize with data
and so we'll simply run the reinforced
algorithm which I think Chelsey
mentioned last week where we'll sample
data from our from our policy and then
we'll compute the policy gradient to
update the parameters and this is really
just kind of a formalization of trial
and error right you're trying to make
good trajectories more probable and bad
trajectory is less probable ok so how
can we turn policy gradient into a meta
learning algorithm well intuitively what
we want to do is collect and remember
information as we go right as we collect
experience and we want that information
to kind of inform the next action that
we take so this kind of starts sounding
like a recurrent Network so let's just
try plugging that in for the policy so
the idea is our policy is just going to
be a recurrent Network we're gonna train
with policy gradient as usual and we're
going to train across a bunch of
different meta training tasks right so
I'll sample a task in this case sledding
I'll roll out a bunch of experience from
it and through my RNN and through each
time step that I accumulate I'll be
updating the hidden state of the Arnon
right which will inform my next action
and so as I train across all of these
tasks I'll be optimizing theta such that
I get theta star and what theta star
will represent is like an op like a
learning algorithm for a new task right
where the learning happens through the
recurrent update of the hidden state so
to kind of keep track of all this in the
upper right hand corner I'm just going
to keep that that RL formalism that we
wrote down at the beginning and so now
our choice of F theta here is just an
RNN
right and we're still doing policy
gradient from the outside loop and so
one one note about this is that you may
be wondering like how is this different
from just using your current policy in
general and one difference is that we
want to persist the hidden state across
episodes right because we may want
adaptation to extend across many
episodes okay so what are the pros of
this method it's pretty general and it's
pretty expressive right are nuns are
very powerful models one con is that
it's not consistent and what I mean by
consistent is that we don't really have
a guarantee that the RNN learning
algorithm will converge or what it will
converge to right we're just hoping that
by optimizing at the outer loop it'll do
something reasonable okay let's think
about a different approach so what if we
made the inner loop look just like the
outer loop so remember the outer loop is
policy gradient what if we just do
policy gradient on the inner loop too
and you guys have seen this already this
is mammal right model agnostic meta
learning and so the idea is we're trying
to find some parameters theta such that
when we take a few gradient steps on
that theta we'll get to a theta star
that's optimal for a given MVP right so
here we'd expect theta star 3 to be
optimal for skateboarding and theta star
- to be optimal for surfing so again in
our little figure up on the right now
the outer optimization is PG and the
inner one is also so what's a promise
it's consistent because now the
adaptation step is gradient descent
right and we know what gradient descent
converges to it converges in nonlinear
settings to local minima and it's clear
that in the limit of enough data it
would just reduce to reinforcement
learning so we know that we would
eventually acquire the optimal behavior
so this is a nice property one con is
that it's not as expressive as the
recurrent model so
chin can you think of an example an
example MDP in which the recurrent
method would be more expressive
so what happens if the rewards are zero
or if the in general if the rewards are
sparse so if the rewards are sparse then
what is the policy gradient look say say
you get one trajectory and you get
collect zero rewards what does the
policy gradient update look like it's
zero like you don't update at all which
is kind of silly because you actually
should have learned some information
from getting no rewards right first of
all you learned about the dynamics of
the new environment which may have
changed and second of all you learned
that that's a really bad place to go
because you didn't get any rewards but
this formulation is not really able to
capture that whereas the recurrent
method we saw before would be able to
okay so let's look about hat look at how
mammal based algorithms learn to explore
so here's a computation graph of what's
happening when you adapt with mammal so
you start with your policy PI theta
right on the left and then you collect
some data now some trajectories and we
use those trajectories to do an update U
which is a step of policy gradient and
that gets us our adopted policy PI theta
prime in the middle right now what are
we gonna do we're going to again collect
data with our adopted policy
that'll be tau prime and we'll evaluate
right well we'll look at the rewards
that we got for those trajectories so
the goal is to assign credit like give
credit for those rewards to both the
adopted policy and the pre adapted
policy right because the pre adaptive
policy should get credit for doing
whatever exploratory behavior led to
good results later on so that's exactly
what happens so if you write out the
gradient what you get is is this kind of
credit assignment where it takes the
structure of the problem into account so
it takes that causal relationship
between the Tau Prime and the theta
parameters into account when when we
compute that great yet
and our l-squared is similar right
except for now it's happening in the
context of an RNN
so through backdrops through time the
steps you took earlier in the trajectory
are getting credit for the awards
received at the end of the trajectory
and if you want a few more details and
and derivation for how this works out
it's it's kind of interesting and you
can find it in this paper Rothfuss at
all 2018 and I'll also have the
reference at the end of the slides okay
so we've just kind of hand waived our
way through with the with the idea that
these algorithms are capable of learning
to explore and if we could optimize them
perfectly they would learn good
exploration trajectories so let's look
at how they actually do in practice so
this on the left is the recurrent
approach tree that we saw first and the
goal here is to adapt to new maze
configurations so it's been trained on a
bunch of different looking mazes and now
we're asking it to adapt to this maze
layout here and so the goal is you
always start in the Blue Square and you
want to end up in the Red Square and so
what we're seeing on the left is for
some exploration trajectories and then
on the right the final trajectory that
the recurrent policy produces and so we
see pretty nice coverage of the maze
here right it goes way out kind of
explores one direction and then and then
goes back so it's probably covering more
than 50% of the maze and then on the
right we have a different kind of
example where we have gradient based
meta learning in a kind of navigation
setting so what's happening here is the
rewards are initially sparse around the
initial position and then you start
getting some reward signal as you move
further away so it requires you to learn
exploration trajectories that explore
far enough away from the initial
position and in this case it's working
quite well right we have the blue
trajectories as the exploration
trajectories and they're successfully
going far enough away to get reward
signal such that the yellow trajectories
solve the task yeah
yeah yeah so you just make the policy on
RNN you keep rolling out across episodes
and you train it across a whole set of
tasks yeah yeah it does not work well or
at all in pretty much all of the
research so far it's definitely an
active area of research so in the second
half of the talk I'm going to talk about
one approach that does work for off
policy RL but certainly combining these
approaches with off policy RL is a very
interesting and actively researched
topic but we haven't figured it out yet
okay but in other cases of course it
doesn't work so well so here's an
example of here's gradient based meta
learning trying to explore in this
sparse reward environment and so I'm
just showing two different environments
here and the first agent is the ant and
the second it's this kind of cart thing
and on the right and plotting so the job
of the agent is to navigate out to one
of those little red circles kind of on
the unit circle and so to explore
effectively it needs to be able to reach
that outer rim right so that it can get
any kind of rewards that it can figure
out how to complete the tasks and so
then what's being plotted in these
diagrams is the actual exploration
trajectories that you get when you run
mammal and so you as you can see they're
not able to explore coherently enough in
order to solve these tasks so there's
some more work needed here okay so let's
think about what the problem is
and I want to start by just giving some
intuition for the problem here see if
these work or not okay
okay so here's a video of a child
exploring or what I would call exploring
right and as you can see her behavior is
very kind of coherent like she picks a
strategy and then she executes on that
strategy for some amount of time before
switching right and as a result she's
able to kind of explore in much more
meaningful states right she's not waving
her arm around out here away from the
box she's exploring in the states that
are relevant for inserting that shaped
peg into the box right and then by
contrast here's what exploration in RL
usually looks like so this is at
hyperspeed
but as you can see it's not doing it's
not exploring in the same kind of
meaningful States right it's spending
most of its time not interacting with
the object and just kind of like doing
random exploration in the joints so what
we'd really like is develop a method
that that has this temporal coherency
that we see on the left right okay so
now getting a bit more technical let's
think about this problem bit more so we
know that we want exploration to be
stochastic right because we need to
collect a whole bunch of diverse data
from different behaviors and whereas
optimal behavior is tremana stick so
optimal behavior and exploration
policies are quite different right and
it can be hard to represent both of
those in the same policy especially when
you have time-invariant action
distributions and typical methods of
adding noise to get that stochasticity
are time invariant right so you might
have a stochastic policy as on the left
but then there's no correlation between
time between the noise of each time step
right or you could noise the policy
parameters but again kind of same
problem so we'd like a bit of a more
explicit way of getting these temporally
coherent trajectories and it seems like
we should be able to use our meta
training tasks to do this right we've
got a whole set of tasks and we should
be able to learn some kind of strategy
that would work well for other tasks of
that
sure so let's build on top of the
gradient based material that we saw so
far and the idea here is we're going to
mount the policy with a latent variable
Z that will inject the structured
exploration into the policy so we're
going to do this by sampling a Z and
holding it so I'm going to refer to that
latent variable as Z so we're going to
sample a Z and hold it constant across
the entire episode right which will give
us our kind of input correlation and
then we'll enforce that that that Z
gives us something relevant to the task
through meta training and the way
they're going to do that is by adapting
the Z to give us optimal trajectories so
the way this is going to work is we're
start we're gonna start with a prior on
Z right we'll sample a Z from that prior
and use that to collect exploration
trajectories then we'll adapt the Z via
gradient descent and we'll then enforce
via meta training that that gives us
optimal trajectories for that task so in
the RL diagram on the upper right again
our outer loop is still policy gradient
but our inner loop is now policy
breeding on these Z variables any
questions about this yeah
now here I'm using the gradient based
approach so all the policies will just
be feed-forward and what we'll do
adaptation to be a gradient descent okay
and of course the result we're hoping to
get is if your job is to pick up one of
these shapes here rather than doing kind
of random eco here an exploration we
expect the agent to systematically
explore by picking up each different
block okay so this was a method that was
published and called Mason and so here
we're gonna look at some results from
that paper so here the task is to push
one of these colored blocks across the
table and the agent is this kind of
disembodied gripper here and so we're
going to compare what happens when you
do mammal and when you do Mason which is
that structured exploration we just
talked about so when you do mammal we
find that the exploration is kind of
random and incoherent and doesn't
succeed at pushing any of the blocks
across and so it doesn't is not able to
get a signal about which one is correct
whereas if we trained with this latent
variable model the exploration policy
systematically pushes blocks across the
table because it knows that the task
distribution involves that right so it
just needs to figure out which one okay
any more questions about this method
yeah
yeah so this is the meta trained policy
yep yep can you elaborate I see I see
right so an episode only contains a
single task you can't switch tasks in
the middle of an episode so if you were
to think about the more realistic
setting of kind of continual learning
then we would basically break it up into
we could potentially make episode and
task be the same boundary just whenever
the reward changes or that I have
exchanged right so you have kind of
choices here about how long you want to
stick with the current latent variable
and that's kind of here sick cool
okay the reward
I believe the reward is sparse until you
get so far to the right so you need the
you need yeah I'm not sure if you might
get our order when you move the wrong
block - I'm not sure but I think it's
only for the right one okay so let's
take a bit of stock of where we are so
what do we want from em at RL algorithm
and we're going to compare the three
that we've looked at so far so we have
the recurrent one the gradient one or
mammal and the structured exploration
one or Mason so we talked about
consistency we said that the recurrent
ones not consistent but the gradient one
and it's derivative of course are talked
about X facility and Y the gradient
based ones are not as expressive we
talked about structured exploration and
how we can like endow the policy with
the capability for structured
exploration but finally what about
efficient and off policy algorithms so
everything that we talked about so far
has been based on policy gradient and
policy gradient is very sampling
efficient right because partly because
it's on policy so it has to collect new
data each time it wants to do an update
so we haven't looked at this question at
all yet but this question is pretty
important and we know from single task
reinforcement learning that off policy
algorithms are one to two orders of
magnitude more efficient in terms of
samples right and they can achieve just
as high performance so this is something
that we'd really like and it also makes
a huge difference for real-world
applications so if we're talking for
example about wanting to run meadow RL
on a robot the all the algorithms we
just looked at would be kind of
hopelessly sample inefficient I
calculated with kind of a frequency
control frequency of 20 Hertz and say
you ran the robot continuously and it
would take about a month to train mammal
on the
but for for a reasonable task
distribution and so if we if we could
bring these off policy methods to bear
we would cut that down to maybe ten
hours and we get out we could run that
so this is a really important question
that we're going to look at next okay so
why is off policy Mehta are L difficult
as a disclaimer this is a very much
unresolved question and there's active
research into trying to figure this out
and it's also very related to why off
policy RL is hard to so that's a lot of
the reasons overlap but one reason that
I want to point out is the key
characteristic of meta-learning is that
the conditions at meta training and meta
test time should match right so what I
mean by this is let's go back to the
image classification case and let's say
that your meta training distribution
consisted of classifying these dogs
these Dalmatians German Shepherds and
pugs now when you go to learn a new
class you're gonna have a much easier
time learning to classify corgis which
are kind of in distribution versus say
motorcycles which are not right and so
we can make the same statement about our
L so when we have our meta trained
policy and we run it we roll it out in
our new task that's going to be on
policy right we're going to be
collecting on policy data that we want
to adapt from but we just said we wanted
to make use of off policy data during
méditerranée
so now we're presented with this kind of
distribution shift where we know that we
have to be able to use on policy data
but we don't want to have to use it
exclusively during méditerranée
so that's what we're taking out and then
after the break we'll talk about how
we're going to address this problem with
a policy RL okay so we're gonna switch
gears just a bit and talk about kind of
a different way to think about meta
reinforcement learning and then we'll
circle back to how this in
facts are design of an off policy
algorithm okay so pom DPS a pom DP is
just a partially observed MVP right so
what does that mean that means that we
have some state which is unobserved to
us but we have access to observations
which are here at note it is au which
give us kind of incomplete information
about the state and so an example of
this might be that you have incomplete
sensor data there might be occlusions
perhaps you to do the task you need an
estimate of your velocity but you only
have an estimate of your position things
like this are kind of usual examples of
a pom DP so it's a very very general
framework and in general very very
difficult to solve so let's see how we
can put our meta RL problem into this
pom VP framework so if we write down
matter RL as a kind of graphical model
then what we have is essentially an MDP
right but where the rewards and the
dynamic functions are also dependent on
this task variable and in general we
don't observe the task variable right
that's our job during adaptation it kind
of we could think of adaptation as
figuring out what that ask is right and
so we can just redefine things a little
bit and put this in the pom EP formalism
so let's just call that hidden state to
be the concatenation between our two
state and the task and now we don't
observe it anymore because we don't know
the task and we'll just redefine our
observations to be the state and the
rewards so you could extend this a
little bit more into a partially
observed meta RL problem right where you
there's also some other part of the
state that you don't observe say you're
doing meta RL from images or something
but for now let's assume that we do
observe the state and the only thing we
don't observe is that task
okay so let's think about how we might
go about trying to solve a pom DP so a
good strategy might be to maintain a
belief distribution over what state were
in right so let's take this really toy
grid world just for an example so
there's three states and they're called
s0 s1 and s2 and you're the the circle
agent and you start in the far left and
in this MVP the the goal is to get to
state two right and you get no rewards
until you get to state two and then you
get a reward of one so when you first
start out the episode you don't know
where you are right so you might assume
a uniform prior over what you think your
state is assuming you have no other
information so that's what I'm
illustrating there on the right with the
blue boxes okay so now let's say we take
an action left we hit the wall we don't
go anywhere we're still in state zero
and we were going to get a reward of
zero so now I know exactly where I am
because I just hit the wall right so I
could say with 100% certainty I'm in the
leftmost state okay so how does this
work for when we're thinking about the
meta RL pom DP so now we're considering
a whole set of MVPs right so let's take
the same grid world but let's define
three MVPs on it and I'm just gonna
change the reward function between MDPs
so for MDP zero you get a reward of one
if you're in the leftmost four MDP one
you get a reward if you're in the middle
so forth so now let's say you have
observed where you are but you don't
know what the task is right that's
that's your job in matter all you wanna
figure out what the task is so let's say
again that you start out with no prior
knowledge you have a uniform belief that
you could be in any of the tasks and now
let's say you take the same action you
go left you hit the wall you're still in
state zero you get zero reward
well now you can update your belief
right because you know you're definitely
not an MVP zero because if you were you
would have gotten a reward so we can do
this and as we can take more actions we
can update the belief more and more so
we have a better idea
of what tasks we're in right and as we
get a better idea we can act more and
more optimally okay so now we have an
idea for what a belief is and how we
would go about updating it how are we
going to use it to pick actions so
basically what I mean is given this
belief how does the policy use it to to
do something to to explore so the
strategy I'm going to talk about is
posterior sampling or a Thompson
sampling and the idea is that you take a
sample from the belief and then act as
if that sample was the truth so as an
example of this suppose that we sampled
that we were in MD p0 from our belief we
picked the first bin so we should then
take the action as if that was the MVP
that we're in and the optimal action in
that case is to go left right because
then you hit the wall and you stay in
the state and you would accrue rewards
if that was the MVP that you were in of
course in this case it's not the MVP
that you're in right so then you can
update your belief as we have there on
the lower right and you can repeat the
procedure you can sample again maybe
this time you sample that you're an MD
p2 right and then you would move right
because that would be the optimal
strategy so as you do this posterior
sampling you're smoothly trading off
between exploration and exploitation
right because as you collect more
experience you're narrowing your belief
distribution so you get a better and
better idea of in this case what tasks
you're in okay so we're going to use
that intuition to build an algorithm so
just as we had before what we want to do
is maintain a posterior belief over the
task and update it so we're gonna call
that P of Z given C so C here is going
to denote context but context or
adaptation data same thing okay so and
we're going to make it a continuous
distribution so this is our continuous
belief distribution P of Z given C and
we're going to get it from our
adaptation data right
then where our women will sample from
that distribution and our agent will use
samples from that belief in order to
explore just like we talked about with
posterior sampling so now kind of going
back again to our little RL framework on
the upper right hand corner now our
function f which used to be for example
an RNN used to be gradient descent now
it's a stochastic encoder right it's
that Phi thing that's going to take our
data and produce our belief distribution
so before we get into how we're going to
make all of this work practically let's
take a look at the results that we want
to get so this would be this is
posterior sampling in action for a real
continuous control domain so you're the
agent you start at that gray circle and
you know from meta training that your
goal is somewhere on that unit circle
kind of denoted as well as a arc but you
don't know where on the unit circle your
goal is and you only get a reward when
you're within the current goal so you in
this example you only get a reward when
you're within that blue circle so what
we would hope is that if that belief
represents our kind of task distribution
right which we know is all along that
arc then when we sample from the belief
essentially what we're doing is we're
sampling different goals along that arc
right and when we sample a goal what do
we do we act optimally according to it
so we act as if for example the goal was
way over there on the right hand side of
course we soon find out that it's not
because we get zero reward but this
gives us kind of a easy way to eliminate
hypotheses and narrow our estimate for
where the goal would be and this is
actually data from the algorithm that
we're going to build up okay so how do
we make this work in practice
well inferring the true posterior P of Z
given C as in tractable so we're going
to use variational inference so we'll
approximate the posterior with Q of Z
given C
and we'll parameterize that distribution
by Phi so it'll be fat distribution will
be the output of some nonlinear neural
network and similarly we'll give an
approximation for the prior and so we
can write down the elbow just like this
and this is the same elbow that you guys
saw before when Chelsea drives
variational inference just probably with
a bit of different notation so the first
term right is the likelihood term and
the second term we might call the
regularization term or the information
bottleneck so let's think about
semantically what this equation means
right so we're trying to maximize this
likelihood term subject to some to the
regularization constraint right and the
likelihood term is supposed to give us a
belief over the task
so what supervision can we use for a
belief over the task so we have choices
we could for example reconstruct the
reward and transition functions right if
we did that then we know that our
representation has the information of
what I'm VP its it is because it's able
to reconstruct the rewards and
transitions another option we can use
which is the one we're going to choose
here is we could adopt the bellman error
and so this will just be essentially
training a cue function and of course
bellman error is not actually a
likelihood but if you squint a little
and you read the controller's inference
tutorial it might start to look like one
and so we're just going to wave our
hands a bit and and say that that's okay
maybe a more intuitive way to think
about it though rather than is the
bellman error likelihood is to think
about it as information bottleneck so in
the information bottleneck point of view
you want to maximize that first term
that our term right subject to the
subject to the Kael constraint and what
that means is you want to pass enough
information through that Z such that you
get good predictions for our write such
that you get good bellman error but you
don't want to pass any more information
than that and that's what the Kael term
does right the K term tries to maximize
the entropy so it says less information
the bellman error says more information
and so as you have these kind of two
competing objectives what she'd get is
just the information you need for the
bellman error does that make sense any
questions about hope this
cool okay so one more thing before we're
ready to put that ger them together is
we didn't really talk about what the
structure of that fly is right I just
kind of waved my hands and said it was a
neural network that takes in all of your
experience and produces this
distribution great but let's look inside
that a bit more and see how we want to
design that element so remember our goal
is to just infer a belief over the task
and to do that because of the Markov
property we don't actually have to
retain the order of the transitions that
we saw them in right so it doesn't
matter for all the transitions we've
seen so far it doesn't matter that we
encode them in the order we saw them
because of the Markov property all we
need is s a s prime are right and that
defines their Ord function and the
transitions so we can encode them in a
totally permutation invariant way which
is exactly what we're going to do and so
what we're going to do is just take each
tuple si s prime R and encode it
independently to produce a Gaussian
factor and then multiply those Gatien
factors together to get a Gaussian
posterior and we're gonna use gaussians
because they make the repair
motorisation trick nice so why would we
want to do this as opposed to using an
RNN well mostly for implementation
reasons because it this is this approach
is going to be faster to train more
stable to Train and generally kind of
simple architectures are gonna are going
to work better you can also replace this
with an RNN and probably with a bit more
tuning you'll also also work ok so we're
almost ready to construct the algorithm
but now we need to talk about off policy
RL so we can put that piece in ok so
here we're gonna build on the algorithm
soft doctor critic and I'm not gonna go
too deeply into this but I'll give some
pointers for references if you're
interested so let's just kind of look at
it from a high level so the soft part
was that mean that means
maximize rewards right so in this
equation at the top or maximize expected
returns that's same from policy gradient
but then also maximize the entropy of
the policy and they do this in soft
doctor critic because they want it gives
them like some better exploration
properties when they're when they're
learning okay and then the actor critic
part what does that mean
well we just model both the actor and
the critic as kind of separate agents
right and we're going to train the
critic which is the cue function here
with the bellman error and then we're
going to train the actor to take actions
that give us high Q values and also give
us high entropy and for the derivation
of like how all of this kind of falls
out I would refer you to the controllers
inference tutorial by Sergei 11 as well
as the original essay see paper is this
enough detail for going forward yeah
right so it's here it's not yeah
basically yeah it's basically the same
I think that would take maybe more diver
divergence but basically like they're so
sack is derived from a framework where
you model the whole thing as a
probabilistic graphical model and then
you can basically relate the probability
of your trajectory being optimal to your
the exponent of your rewards and once
you kind of make this assumption then
you can then you can basically like that
assumption basically leads directly to
this algorithm and ATC like doesn't
start from that kind of framework
okay so just of just some results from
this algorithm it does pretty good on
humanoid and they ran it on this kind of
cool clawed robot at Berkley and aliens
to turn the valve and so this this
algorithm right now is is kind of
highest-performing in most sample
efficient algorithm that that we're
using and so we're really interested in
being able to build on top of this
algorithm for our meta learning uses
okay so here's kind of a simplified soft
doctor critic in a diagram form and so
it's off policy we're gonna maintain a
replay buffer as we collect data and
we're going to optimize both the actor
and the critic with their respective
losses okay so now let's add our task
belief distribution on top of this
algorithm so how's that going to work so
again we're going to maintain this
approximate belief posterior the Q of Z
given C right and we're going to take
samples from it and pass those to the
actor and critic so now the actor and
critic essentially are getting a state
that's the concatenation of the original
state of the MVP with the Z variable
right and where Z here includes is
representing a task ID in some sense
right and I got kale term comes from the
the regularization from the racial
inference as we talked about before and
you'll notice that we back propagate the
credit clause into the encoder and
that's the bellman error likelihood term
that we saw before
okay so now let's just look at some
results from this algorithm that we've
put together so I'm gonna show results
on these four domains and so the agents
we're going to be looking at are the g2
human right ant and Walker and we'll
look at meta training distributions that
differ both in reward function and in
dynamics so for the first three agents
we're going to look at a variable reward
function so that means which direction
you move in your target velocity or a
goal position and then for the final
agent will look at varying dynamics so
that will be like the the masses and
physical parameters of the agent so here
is the first three so the first
algorithms that we looked at excuse me
evaluated on these tasks so in that
light greenish color we have our l
squared which is an instantiation of the
recurrent method that we talked about at
the beginning and then in purple and in
yellow we have kind of two variants of a
gradient based approach and so this is
just kind of for baseline how well
things do and we're on a log scale here
which is why the curves kind of trend up
like that word that way okay and then in
blue here is the algorithm that we just
put together so it's as you can see it's
about 20 to 100 times more sample
efficient and is also outperforming the
previous approaches and the reason I was
able to do this is because it's
leveraging that off policy algorithm si
see that we just talked about in the
meta learning context okay so why does
this view that we took of meta RL as a
pom VP and wanting to have a belief over
the task why does that make off hollow
crl easier like going back to that
question where I was showing the
distribution of the dogs and like it's
better if you have tests Ostra bution
how does this help us with that so the
interesting thing is that this approach
allows us to separate the data that we
use to infer the task right at the top
with Phi from the data that we use to
train the RL Ajay
and so what this means is that we can
address the distribution shift by making
that adaptation data on policy but
making the rest of the data used to
train the actor critic off policy so and
this can still get as big sample
efficiency speed ups because if you
think about it probably a lot of the
data that you're using is to figure out
how to to figure out policy behaviors
that are like common across all of the
tasks right so in the example of
navigating to different positions the
knowledge of just how to walk at all is
not task specific right and we can learn
that off policy through kind of the
bottom half of this figure whereas the
top half which goes through SC can be on
policy and we have this kind of knob
that we can turn to test you know how
off policy can we make that data or not
that make sense yes
right so actually no parameters change
at all all the parameters of the model
are fixed so it's like the RNN case and
not in that regard
right where after Mediterranea is done
your parameters are fixed so then what's
what's changing here is the Z that the
belief distribution the Q of Z given C
so as you accumulate data right you are
updating your estimate of the belief
with with the meta trained five
parameters yeah yeah I mean kind of by
construction it because of this
multiplication it tends to decrease and
then at some point it it just kind of
stabilizes yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah so why are else oh she is - no
IRL squared or a pro MP was better on
that one there's like two versions of
humanoid let me get back to you on that
but in general the different algorithms
so pro MP is basically mammal but it's
implemented on top of a different policy
gradient algorithm so mammal is built on
top of TRP oh just trust reason policy
optimization and pro MP's built on top
of PPO and there's some like little
things you have to do to make that work
PPO in general is kind of it just about
better performing algorithm so in
general propia outperforms mammal and
then our l squared here also is
implemented on top of PPO which actually
makes it improve a lot more over
previous results which were usually
plotted with TRP oh so there's a lot of
variables in RL and you kind of have to
get all of them right to really have a
very comparison the other thing while
I'm thinking about that humanoid thing
the other thing I would say is that
these curves are a bit misleading in
terms of if you actually care about what
the agents are doing it's not really
working and in some of the cases so for
example in that humanoid case what you
want is the humanoid to run forward or
backward or in different directions but
none of these algorithms are actually
achieving that reward so this algorithm
in blue is essentially just standing up
for longer than other algorithms so I
think that kind of points to the
difficulty of optimization in red RL in
general because we know we can train a
single task policy with Si Si on
humanoid right
but when we go to the medic case were
not able to achieve that same
performance so the the curves can be a
little misleading in some cases that's
the only one that it that's the only
environment here where that's true the
other ones actually do the tasks to some
degree okay we talked about that so I
talked about some limitations of this
method so posterior sampling is pretty
good and there's a reference at the end
for a paper that that shows you can show
a regret bound for posterior sampling
that's pretty good but it's not optimal
obviously and here like this the same
diagram that I showed it off with also
shows off why it's not optimal right
because if you're in this environment
the best thing to do is to go out to the
taxes a to the ark and simply walk along
the ark until you find the goal and
posterior sampling can't do this and so
the algorithm we built also can't do
this so it's in some cases it's going to
have you know potentially pretty bad
exploration or pretty far from optimal
exploration so one kind of interesting
way to look at this I think is is to
look at the difference between that
Mason algorithm that we saw in the first
half and what we just designed here so
to get a bit into the details the
difference is in how you can strain that
Leighton distribution and if you
constrain it before you do the
adaptation or after and so graphically
the difference is that in the algorithm
we saw before the so let's look the
yellow B the prior Z distribution right
you start off with samples from the
prior and then when you adapt your
distributions move away from that prior
and that's because you're constraining
the the pre updated distribution to be
close to the unit gash in right not the
post updated one so
essentially that kind of separates your
exploration trajectories which are in
the yellow region from your task optimal
trajectories which are in the different
blue regions depending on the task
versus the method we just described what
we just built up that's the policy
method Perl what it's doing is its
constraining the post adapted Z
distribution to the prior right remember
that kale regularization term
so essentially what that's doing is
trying to get all of the task
distributions to kind of overlap with
each other and with the prior and so
essentially in the in the parallel
approach you're not going to learn you
have no chance of learning optimal
exploration trajectories right the
latent distribution you learn is is
simply over the task distribution and so
all the exploration trajectory is that
you sample will just be optimal ones for
some other task okay so in summary we
first looked at how building on policy
gradient RL we can implement different
meta RL methods with recurrence or with
optimization we looked at how adaptation
in matter RL is both an exploration and
an adaptation problem and we looked at
how we can improve exploration by
conditioning the policy on latent
variables and in the second half we
looked at how mad RL is a particular
kind of palm DP and how using that kind
of intuition we can build up an
algorithm that estimates a belief over
the task and integrates well with off
policy RL I other questions yeah
here I'm not sure if that's actually the
case or if it's actually a problem with
how we record it I think I might be a
problem over the frequency of how we
recorded the data yeah it could it could
be a bit more unstable I mean in general
off call us algorithms tend to be more
unstable than on policy ones though
software actor critic in the single-task
results is pretty stable in like in
where oh yes yeah the metal world paper
yeah yeah so that paper is just to give
some context that paper is interesting
and they made so this was people at
Berkeley and Stanford they made a data
set of robot manipulation tasks in
Morocco that they have like 50 different
tasks and they're quite different tasks
so here we're looking at things like
cheetah running at 10 meters per second
versus 20 meters per second but in this
meta world tasks distribution they're
actually looking at things you know like
picking pushing moving things that you
would actually consider to be different
tasks and they evaluate these algorithms
that we've looked at on this benchmark
of tasks and yeah I'm not I actually
haven't seen the results myself I just
heard about it so I would say that in
general so I'll follow crl to begin with
is is um less stable than on policy
partly for like the same distribution
shift reason that we talked about
earlier right like you're expected to
learn from data that's not from your
current dish
tribution right so that's that's one
problem and the second problem going
against it is the meta training
optimization is itself hard and that's
hard even just in a multitask setting so
for example forget about the adaptation
stuff and just try to train a policy
that can do 50 different tasks given
some indication of what task is solving
that in itself is a difficult
optimization problem because what ends
up happening is the gradients from the
different tasks can I kind of interfere
with each other and like kind of lock
and prevent the the model from learning
anything so I think those two problems
combined are are what's causing the
issue and I think looking at each of
them in isolation will kind of yield
progress that we can then put back
together
ya know but sort of in the sense that so
it's so sort of yes but through the data
rather than through disease so what I
mean by that is when we collect data we
collect some of it with the policy
conditioned on a Z from the prior and
some of it with a Z that's conditioned
on sorry with a Z that's computed from
posterior trajectories so essentially
get that effect but it's through the
data in the buffer
yeah so doing some kind of like priority
prioritization over the replay buffer so
yeah I'm not sure how addressing the
distribution chef's shift explicitly I
mean I guess so okay we're kind of we're
kind of we're kind of doing that right
when we sample the context from the
replay buffer so that SC thing is is
representing like a sampling operator
which essentially only samples the most
recent things so that the data is on
policy as possible so that seems like
kind of what you're getting at in terms
of addressing the distribution shift
yeah in general there's I mean there's
other techniques for like how you might
better sample from the replay buffer
that you could probably marry with this
right because remember at test time it's
a brand new task yeah so one well okay
that's another thing but yes yeah sorry
yep yeah so si si uses a target network
already and we just yeah we also used
that yeah it is a bit of a moving target
um one thing you could consider doing is
if you like if you were not using the
bellman era to train the encoder if you
were using like reconstructing the
rewards and the transitions then you
could train that offline beforehand
right and then do this and I haven't
experimented with that in particularly
I've experimented with training it all
in parallel but with a reconstruction
the reward reconstruction objective
instead of the bellman error and it it
does a bit worse yeah
yeah I think especially so it that does
work in have situations where
exploration is not as important so for
example in the mucho Co benchmarks where
you get dense rewards at every time step
that actually works fine but it doesn't
work for example in this farce this guy
this case but in general I think getting
an off policy method that can learn off
that has that property of being able to
learn optimal exploration trajectories
is kind of an open question I haven't
got anything to work there yet
so in our l squared you don't carry the
hidden state across the task only the
episode right because the hidden state
in RL squared is supposed to tell you
what task you're in essentially or
suppose to give you some task specific
information so one interesting idea
which we tried and didn't work is sort
of getting at this idea of like can we
use different data from different tasks
for what so sorry can I take data from
task a and like use it for task B like
why can't I do that that's annoying so
if you wanted to do that what you'd have
to do is like real able the data right
so say because you say the reward
function changes between task and task B
if I could real able task a data with it
has to be reward function I could use it
and that'd be great great so what we
tried to do is essentially put a model
for the rewards that's trained from Z so
basically have Z reconstruct the rewards
and so if we essentially have a
generative model of rewards and we train
this across all the meta training tasks
so now it should be that given a Z I get
some reward function and then I could
use that reward function to really able
some data it didn't work but I think in
I think figuring out how to reuse data
from tasks for each other would be
really useful in terms of making us more
sample efficient
yeah probably
um yeah I mean if you're in a sparse
award case then you're you're like any
kind of signal is going to help you a
lot versus if you're in this case where
you have some label data and you just
want to kind of generate more to help
you like it's it's less clear if it'll
help you I guess cool I heard this ends
at 250 so thanks all for coming
[Applause]